this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 4th of may from the heart
of new jersey the joint is brought to
you by draftkings it's a big weekend
this weekend we got nfl playoffs we got
baseball but we got ufc 274
new customers can bet five dollars on
any fighter to win and get 150
and free bets if they do we got aloe
vera against gagey you got a tremendous
card this week so choose your fighter
sit back and watch the action unfold and
collect some [__] money because
anything could happen on fight night but
you got a short thing with draftking
sports book bet five dollars and get a
hundred and fifty in free bets
draftkings the official sports betting
partner of ufc 274
download the draftking sports book app
right now it's wednesday let's get a
jump on it you got basketball playoffs
and you got baseball download the
draftking sports book app use code joey
you throw down a fin on any ufc 274
fighter to win and you get a hundred and
fifty dollars in free bets if they do
it's that easy
this is the biggest card of the year
oliver engaging we've been waiting a
[__] year for this and it's here this
saturday
ufc on draftkings that's code joey this
saturday at draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply and the joint is also brought to
you by my personal favorite
cbd lion let me tell you some of those
do those new delta nines they got a
[__] stronger than debt and they
deliver them right to your house
and then you can bandage yourself with
the kinesiology tape you could smoke the
[__] cbd hemp you could rub the cream
on your foot listen cbd lion is number
one in my [__] book go to cbdline.com
read the third party lab results and
knock yourself out
this will tell you exactly what you need
how to use it
that's what cbd line's about go to
cbdline.com
press in joey and get 20 off your order
and that's 20 off the delta 9 still
delivered right to your house and nobody
knows [__] now without further
ado let's get this [__] party
started jack
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the fourth of [__] may
one more day and you'll be jumping up
and down to the mexican restaurant
that's the truth right everybody loves
[__] cinco de mayo you don't even
know why you're jumping up and down you
don't even like mexicans and you're
jumping up and down
[__] tequila [__] bean dip and
farts you [__] love it
my main man is in here today john
bernthal on a wednesday
to get this [__] party started
we talk the podcast we'll talk we on the
night we'll talk in generalities what's
going on brother it's great to see you
man it's great to be here with you in
jersey in your home man south [__]
jersey beautiful man central jersey good
to see you man now you know man what's
going on with you yeah i'm happy for you
i love seeing you out here talking to
your wife
seeing how great your daughter's doing
out here how much you love this
community how much the community loves
you it's great i [__] love it i love
it down here you know i can tell i felt
bad this morning because i had to go i
go to a health food store yeah that guy
has had that health food store for 30
[__] years wow so you could go to him
with any question like i want a bag of
heroin
let me call my friend you know
i was just in there this i had to go get
uh stuff from my knees have like a stuff
to strengthen your uh tendons stuff you
put in or stuff you rub on it stuff you
put in water in the morning so i take it
with my vitamins in the morning yeah
it's like glucamine mixed with something
else okay something it works
[__] yeah yeah pain in my left knee at
all but i went there this morning
and some salesmans was there when i
walked in he's like telling the guy i
[__] this [__] don't work the guy's
missing teeth
he's built [__] up he takes crayton
every day
he lives on kratom whatever the [__]
that is creatine great time
kratom yeah kratom yeah i don't know
what the [__] is some green [__] yeah
but he lost his teeth [__] dog yeah
besides that he's like a [__] pillar
of [__] hell this guy has eaten
everything at that when you go in there
and you go i want to try that he'll go
don't do it yeah i did this for a while
it didn't work out for me like he's
tried everything in there well wow
everything what when i was sick when i
was sick i went in and i go this is
what's going on man he gave me crayton
well and it's like red crayton it's like
a japanese herb or something like that
that they grind up and it's supposed to
be illegal
right but i guess everybody in this area
is heavy on the crate is that right you
get juice the night before and you put
like four tablespoons in and you put it
in your refrigerator and when you wake
up in the morning you drink it
and it [__] sets you out for the day
and they have a red like a green hulk is
good like the red dragon you do it
anything red is to relax but that's not
just for the knees that's for general no
no this is for everything this is to get
high i think did you did you did you
ever do like the thai boxing liniment on
on the knees have you ever done that no
that is the [__] [__] do you know in
the movie you and i the first movie you
and i did together in [__] new
orleans uh sylvester stallone he [__]
went yeah my son had just been born my
my son bill had just been born he was
stuck at the nicu right because he was
super [__] early so i go down there
for rehearsal
and i fly home to go meet my son
literally like meet my son for the first
time at my house and when i when i land
in the airport at lax i get a call from
my agents they said sly wants you back
in new orleans for boxing rehearsal like
[__] boxing marvels because you
remember i was i did the part but then i
also did young de niro because they
found out box a little bit whatever so
i'm like i could go and meet my kid like
what i got to go box with sylvester
stallone they like they need you back
there so i get back on the [__] plane
and i go to this boxing rehearsal and
he's in the ring with uh
with with de niro and he's kind of like
you know like all the executives are
kind of watching him and he's kind of
holding court doing his thing
and i walk in he goes yo you're next you
know and i'm like all right so like you
know i just started hitting the bag
whatever
and then they finish the rehearsal he
[__] walks out of the ring and i came
back for no [__] reason right and i'm
like well look what am i doing here and
then i met this kid greg rementers now
this huge stunt stunt guy he was playing
the young stallone so we were like hey
man we're here you want to just go in
the ring and get a few rounds of
sparring and say cool
so i go up into the ring
and this woman comes up and she comes to
the ring she goes hey i just went into
your bag you have that thai boxing
liniment and and and sly really loves
that boxing liniment so i went into your
bag and i took i'm gonna go rub it on
his back
and i'm like you went into my bag and
took my [__] liniment you know what i
mean that liniment's really [__] hard
to get but i got bad knees too and it's
great for about like if you're gonna
move it just it just makes everything uh
numb you know what i mean
so i go all right fine like you'll
[__] rub it on his back like i came
here for no reason i'm sparring with
greg and now like he's getting all my
boxing linemen on his back
so the [__] sparring is done about 45
minutes later he comes out he's been you
know massaged he's showered he comes out
in this like beautiful [__] suit and
a top hat you know what i mean he walks
i go yo i'll see you later you know
let's walking out she comes back over
she goes hey i just want to let you know
sly's just going to go ahead and hang on
to that boxing limit and i'm like mother
[__] and i completely lost my and i
like ran out after him i had my i still
have my gloves on my mouth go i go slide
like what's going on he's like yo and
i'm like hey look man like where i'm
from if you're gonna borrow something
from someone you know normally you ask
you know permission first like you ask
you know he's like yo i'll let you box
in my gym i was like hey look man like
you made me come down you're like you
know i'm like what are you you you know
and and he was like look i don't need
the litterman you hang on to i said no
keep the [__] line of me you know but
i'm like but you know and we
i thought for sure i was going to get
fired after that you know what i mean
and we it made us start off on such a
wrong [__] path you know what i mean
and that's all i think about with that
[__] box it's the greatest [__] on
earth but but then sly did become super
[__] nice to me he's a great guy and
all that but yeah that's what i thought
of when you talked about your bad knees
now speaking of thai [__] heater that
vitamin guy also told me about a
thailand viagra
that your dick is hard for three days
that they take it in thailand on a
friday and then it's [__] wrong
three days you know when i saw his
missing teeth i was like i don't know
that sounds interesting
but i don't know i don't know you got
missing teeth and i don't want to
[__]
you know take the tie pills and then i
got a hard on for [__] three days i
don't even know who to stick it in as
you see my wife is a christian she don't
play that [__] so you know when i got
married my freaky days were done they're
done just like done so yeah
but no i like the area i uh needed this
you know when people were calling me
saying why are you moving there nobody
really understood like i just wanted
it was time for me to be around my
people yeah yeah it was time to me you
know even though i don't see my friends
as much as i'd like to sure i know
they're there i mean you know when we
moved that la it was the same thing but
like honestly man most important like
sitting down with her and seeing how
happy she is and how much it means to
her to have community and understood
that look everybody wants a [__] on la
but but the truth is there's trappings
of la and if you're trying to raise a
family there it's it there's a lot of
there's a lot of fake nonsense there and
i think that that's really hard you
don't want to raise kids in that
environment and it was great to see how
happy she is and it's great to see how
much your daughter's thriving that's
like that's what we're on this earth to
do man i'm not i don't have a bad thing
to say about that way la served the
purpose for me that's right
and i know listen i thought about moving
to different places in northern
california i thought about moving to
reno yes what she said i thought about
going back to colorado like go towards
telly ride yeah but then the pandemic
came yeah and the pandemic came with
just like this weird feeling to it yeah
it just wasn't it's like right now
you know i was we were talking monday
about the things you never want to think
about you never want to when you're down
200 000 like when you owe 200 000 and
you say to yourself how am i going to
pay this that and you go i'm never going
to pay i don't want to think about it
it's the same thing right now i think i
think america i think the world right
now
we're not in a good place i agree you
know between inflation the numbers are
going back up all this [__] we're not in
a good place and we have a war going on
with a guy that anything could happen
and if you think about how this is gonna
end
it's the same thing as owing two hundred
thousand dollars you don't wanna you
don't wanna think about it there's so
many things you can say so many rapid
rules right now you know that's right so
every one of those arguments sorry to
interrupt you but every one of those
sort of topics is being taken over by
folks that just want to get you on their
side or the other side they just want to
make it so hey i i'm with these these
guys are these guys they just want to
wave their [__] flags from the
sidelines and and and and that makes it
so you never actually face the issues
you're never actually talking to people
of real experience in the [__] issues
we're talking wrong [__] people the
wrong people got the mic
you know i don't know the issues i just
have i go by feeling yeah and i go by
the direction the wind is gone blowing i
mean i think this is the calm before the
storm yeah for some reason i just
we were talking on monday about you know
how we're worried about our children
that's right what world are our children
going to go into you know all i ever
wanted was to have a child with this
woman
and now our children are going to be
able to buy a house
our children going to be able to have
the same things we had who the [__]
knows yeah
but this is what you know you have to
think about or not think about yeah and
move on but it's a different world right
it's a different one but when you've got
kids it is you know really loving
really understanding what it's like to
love somebody more than you love
yourself and not give a [__] what
happens to you but you just want to
throw down for that kid the only reason
you're on this earth is for that kid and
and it's crazy to actually face
the fact that like you might be leaving
them a world that's worse off than you
came in you think about all the things
you had as a kid you're like wow my my
kid i don't
they can't really experience that you
know like i don't know and i'm sure like
you know i was walking through new york
you know i'm doing that you know down
here for press and i was thinking about
man you imagine new york in the 70s and
the eight you know you always think how
much better was it i remember what it
was like
10 years ago 20 years ago the [__]
energy the palpability of anything could
happen at any [__] moment and just
how electric that was and there was that
that that feeling you know if you can
make it here you can [__] make it any
i don't care what you do but i remember
pounding the [__] pavement as an
actor thinking i didn't have a [__]
hope in the world but i just keep on
grinding keep on pounding the
electricity fueled me but now you're
like you see it and you're like wow like
what are these
what are these kids coming up seeing you
know like everyone's on their [__]
phones but you know then again you maybe
you're just like hey look i'm just an
old [__] like every other miserable [__]
from every other generation who thinks
that like you know kids today don't
don't know anything and they're missing
out on anything and i don't know if
that's just part about life and getting
older
i don't want to be that old [__] me
neither you don't ever want to my day
and the electricity 10 20 years ago in
new york that [__] ain't like i you know
i was out last night in new york it's
cool but that ain't what it was [__]
10 20 years ago no and you should have
had it in the 80s i can only imagine
when it was
like a paradise to go over there yeah
you know living here especially where i
lived i lived
eight minutes from the city right so it
was dessert right right
it was always dessert right we did this
in jersey can you imagine what we're
gonna do in new york at three a.m let's
just go over there get a quesadilla and
see where the [__] where the night
takes us you know new york was a [__]
great place i'm
like i'm too old
but i wish
i could have done a play yeah i can put
all that time you have to play and not
worry
you know bro i got a [__] my agent
[__] uh reached out to me last week
you're not gonna believe this she goes i
sent
this uh department
all my actors and the only one they
wanted to see was you [__] to go up
to yale on monday to yale rep to yale to
college yeah yeah yeah and do a table
read at the david geffen arena or
something that's yeah it's a great
theater go for [__]
and i'm telling you man that is where
the big boys go man [__] all this on
camera [__] i mean it's like great we do
whatever no second takes no nothing like
think with you and your background what
you're able to do like no other comic in
the world you on stage and your acting
ability it would be a fun i would love
to do i would love to do i always do a
play with you i always wanted like i'm
thinking i've been talking to vince
pastor a [__] about doing uh
the one about the butcher
oh uh no no requiem for a dream right
queen for a dream first and then the one
about the butcher with the ugly butcher
that falls in love with the good looking
chick played by ernest borgnine
we always read it in acting class i
forget what the [__] sam or something
like that yeah who the [__] knows
no no it's not sweeney
do i look like sweeney todd to you
but i i always felt
like i always felt when you're a
stand-up you feel very insecure on a set
sure but then again you know like i got
an audition the other day and they i
looked at you know you always look at
[__] and i could tell by reading the
audition that it was a [__] hand job
you know it was it gave you too much
information and then i saw
who's in the movie who casted themselves
in the movie already it's a husband and
wife team his rating on imdb is 400 000
and hers is like six hundred thousand
so they want me to read for this movie i
go and my wife was looking at the phone
i go
it says sag scale but trust me there's a
by the way there you could tell just
and sure enough on the bottom she goes
yeah it's still waiting for sag after
approval i go [__] that because they
just wanna so when you're in a movie you
have a lot of those things you have a
lot of people that just cast themselves
or whatever but i think in theater those
are the high level [__] sure
especially at a place like that
especially you know so you kind of get
but this was yale they were gonna give
me two hundred and ten dollars yeah yeah
there's no money no no money i was
taking a train out of penn station but
then taking an uber home yeah from yale
at 210 is for that uber new haven
connecticut or something like that
straight up holy [__] yeah so they just
wanted me to do the table read so next
time they do contact me i will go up
there yeah i think you should i would
love to that's great but i don't know if
i could do those 80 hour [__]
rehearsals man but you know what like
it's i don't know rehearsals [__]
heaven it's it's [__] heaven it's
where you can try anything that's how
you grow you know it's like all i it's
like getting it's like getting a lot of
time to work on your set but with other
people you know what i mean with other
people inspiring you and challenging you
and there's nothing in the world like
rehearsal i i [__] live for anything
can happen rehearsal you're there to
take risks you're there to fail you're
there to [__] up like when else you get
to do that as an artist
like you it's like look i'm sure you
have your own way of working on what you
work on and you have your own method for
for your comedy right but for an actor
it's like we gotta like carve out our
[__] time to put our work in but this
is determine set you know eight nine ten
hour days where everyone's gotta [__]
be there you gotta be on stage and
everyone's throwing down so it's like
think about the [__] you can discover
and how you can grow we don't get that
it's like playing baseball right like
you [__] play baseball you can work
you can hit off a t you know what i mean
if you don't have anybody else what you
can throw a ball against a [__] tree
right you can like stretch you can work
out but in order to play the game you
got to have a bunch of other people with
all the equipment with the field with
the ball they got to be willing to play
they all going to be allowed to be there
at the same time that's how you get
better at baseball you go to practice
the way you get better as an actor is
you go to play rehearsal you don't do it
by sitting alone in your [__] living
room saying the lines to a mirror you
know you don't say it by like the 10
seconds you get between action and cut
on a film set you know you're driving in
the car you're saying the lines over and
over what [__] practice is that you
know what i mean rehearsal is [__]
where you i love it i love all that [__]
i like when they block on a movie yeah
yeah i love all that i've always loved
i've been doing that for eight hours
dawg i gotta tell
we do the table read yeah raise there
yeah
i respect the [__] out of ray leona you
know i love raleigh
i say how you doing i keep it to a
minimum
he's from union new jersey up the corner
here
so i keep it to a minimum i don't see
ray for like two weeks and we're
shooting and all of a sudden ray shows
up yeah you know and
it's like five in the morning
i'm in my trail of smoking dope and i
finished my joint like you know i go to
makeup and there's ray next to me i
don't say good morning how are you doing
ladies good and also not on the way out
i go ray
not for nothing if you want to rehearse
the lines let me know yeah do you know
this [__] didn't even answer me
[Music]
oh yeah he heard me loud and clear and
he just looked over at me
and he just [__] turned his face i'm
like
[__] [__] right so i'm
now we're getting to the scene yeah it's
a table and sat really [__]
and he's sitting there at the end and
i'm sitting right next to him so i got a
little i don't say a word
so first line comes up hop along
quesadilla yeah what are you talking
about and then he starts with his frank
sinatra dean martin joke
and he's [__] up yeah like he can
yeah we could talk about this i remember
yeah this was like first day he was in
there he's spitting food he's trying to
chew he's fighting food
with the thing in it dave [__]
what's his name leaves
uh
god bless him you know
whatever's david chase he [__]
couldn't take it
[Music]
because the [__] girl came over 20
times ray can you imagine coming over to
him
you know dawg she came over 20 times ray
the line is gone and he's like wiping
his face and [__] like
you're like hey ray you want to rehearse
those lines
so all of a sudden again
action right it [__] up the line i
can't take it no more yeah i go right
maybe you should have [__] read those
lines of me he just looked at me like
you he didn't like me that yeah yeah he
didn't even talk to me
ray you should have [__] rehearsed
those lines you know yeah he got so
angry he just left
did you hear about that he just left we
shot that scene without him i i heard
him look like somebody there shot that
scene without himself he's really older
he's the star of the [__] movie what
are you going to do
you know he's having a bad day i don't
say nothing i'm dying to laugh
i'm dying to laugh he's spitting food
john he's going crazy the guy that's
playing silvio he's like what the [__]
is going on over there this is going on
for three [__] hours four hours
finally ray leaves
he just left nobody said nothing i think
honestly people were like thank god
thank god
together read those lines off the camera
so don't i did not want to laugh yeah
it's my first
time with these people i don't want to
laugh and i don't want to be an [__]
so i'm not saying nothing about it i'm
just sitting there and from time to time
giggling by myself and then at one point
we're sitting there it's gotta be three
in the [__] morning yeah we're there
from six in the morning and [__] yeah
john mcgowan looks at us there's like
six of us and he goes what the [__] was
going on with ray today doug we [__]
lost it because everybody was waiting
for somebody to say what the [__] was
yeah everybody lost it yeah and then we
you know we pack up rap we all get in
the van we're shooting back to the city
we're sitting there with ty and out of
nowhere the makeup lady goes can i ask
you guys a question what was going on
with ray leonard today and this time the
[__] driver of the car the teamster
was like he didn't he busted out because
he's like dawg i was listening to it
what the [__] was going on in there you
know he was just having but then
like i didn't see red
i didn't see him at all maybe one other
day and then i went to see the movie
and you see him in prison you're like oh
[__] he's a [__] killer he's a
[__] killer he's a killer that's
dirty [__] he's acting that's right
you know who i flew out here with man
and wanted me to say hello it's brendan
shout man
what a [__] unbelievable guy here i
was literally listening to him on rogan
and then i'm [__] on the plane and he
says hey man he said says hello to me
sitting like almost right next to me on
the plane i said i'm [__] listening
to you and we start talking about kids
and and you know his kids are in jiu
jitsu too and just man he is such a
[__] good guy like such a good guy he
wanted me to send you love and he's bro
i'm gonna i'm gonna hit him later
because i know he's in the city i'm
gonna get him later yeah it's crazy
because i was when he hit me
yesterday whenever he hit me on
instagram i am back now i'll call you
tonight or something he was going to be
in town until wednesday and yeah
something like that
and i started thinking about brandon and
i started thinking about what brendan's
gone through in his life how
he wasn't that good of a fighter people
made fun of him and then you know
rogan talked him out of fighting which
was a big step
as a friend to tell somebody that
and this kid jumped into comedy with
both hands and
you know years ago i did something with
joe in atlanta and he was there
and he kept looking at me
he was a fighter that i'm on stage doing
stand-up and every time i look in the
audience [__] brendan sharp is like
looking at me with like a weird look so
after the show rogan goes man brendan
sharp
wants to say hello come back and talk to
you i don't want to talk to that
[__]
i swear to god i'm like don't bring him
back here
because that dude don't like me and he
was doing he was watching comedy like
with a weird look on his face i don't
want him back here and rogan's like okay
joey i won't bring him back and and then
i met him
and i realized that he was a student
that's it
what a beautiful humble guy he was a
student he was watching me like [__]
hanging on to the words it's
embarrassing when you see somebody do
that they're either hating on you yeah
or they're [__] going what the [__]
is this guy saying yeah so years later
when i met him we had that conversation
he's like no you were doing a joke about
something i was thinking to myself how
are you getting this out of your mouth
yeah aren't you ashamed or embarrassed
or something so
he reveres you man i see what he's doing
now brilliant
and i give him the thick boy stuff the
special he
produced directed everything himself you
know what and people chop his legs off
yeah like anything like in any so like i
don't know society i mean people chop
his legs off all the time but i just
because they're scared he's different
and that's what we were talking like
when i came in acting i came in from
sports it was you know it's a very
different level but like people saw me
and they're like this guy can't [__]
do this [__] and like man it's so
it's like but you know he's his his
strength and his resilience but like to
come through it on the other end and
just be so kind he's like such a kind
guy he's got a heart of gold and here's
a [__] crazy thing for all the people
that enjoy putting brendan down and
creating stupid jokes
and saying he's not funny the people who
do that had never done anything in their
life and have never faced adversely like
this guy
if i was brendan shaw with all the hate
he's gotten i would have quit by now but
this [__] kept going started
thick boy industries he's always working
and he keeps [__] swinging so for you
[__] that don't think brendan's
funny today yeah
give him a couple years you're going to
be eating your [__] words and the
people that are putting them down are
people who've never done anything that's
right never mind quit being a fighter
and then going into comedy one of the
hardest [__] things you could do ever
ever and you got to give the guy credit
he's remained a sweetheart of a guy i'm
going to see brian this weekend okay i'm
going to hook up with brian at the
stress factory this weekend do some
shows with him he's trying to [__] do
some videos and stuff we're gonna go out
and eat i'm gonna take him to [__]
either the stage
new brunswick got some good food too
yeah but oh i bet they got steakhouse 85
yeah that'll knock you into a different
world and they got a place called the
stage you get the seven ounce why you
beef they cook it on the stone with some
whipped potatoes and [__] i send the
chef a bag of reefers everybody knows
we're [__] solid yeah oh yeah you
have no [__] idea yeah but brendan
you know it's like i i love underdogs i
said i've always loved underdogs i'm an
underdog i always want to be getting
points that's it give me the points i
don't give a [__] i'll take them i'll
[__] rock your world that's right i
rock your [__] world so give me the
points i don't give a [__] that's what
we thrive on yep we thrive on people
going you're not gonna do this okay
watch my [__] smoke i may not do it
perfectly but i'm gonna do it that's
right okay that's right and if i could
do it once i could do it again and again
and again until i [__] get it and
then you're going to reach back and
you're going to try to lift up and
support anybody else who has that same
sort of mentality and that dude's going
through that same kind of thing because
your heart's been through it you say hey
look i see you man i believe in you and
you thought that's what we that's what
we connected on the plane too like that
and just being being dads but i'm just
real taking with that guy man you see
something solid [__] dude you know
and it's like
he came from i mean this kid did you see
the video of him crying [__] did you see
that video and he's like just he's kind
of hard to go
all those guys yeah you know what was
done in comedy a couple of years ago
was a [__] nightmare because those
guys are all sweethearts
crystal is a sweetheart brian's a
sweetheart
[__] brendan is it like a student
like brendan used to call and ask stupid
questions and i'd go but on the flip
side
and i know you've seen this how many
people have come up to you
and said john i want to do what you're
doing or will i ever want to be was an
actor you know i do this i do that but i
can't put the pieces together but you
know they're bullshitting you yeah yeah
they just want a [__] hitch on your
trailer yeah but then you see people who
are savages on their own and you'll do
anything for those people you'll go you
know what man whatever you want
because i see what you're doing yeah and
whatever you're doing
i know that you want that ship and i
know you want that porsche
it's not in your house today that's
right but keep doing what you're doing
you'll have it in two years there you go
and forget the monetary [__] all that
yeah forget the monetary love
it's what you want to do that's why i
didn't want to do stand-up for a year
because i wasn't in love with it anymore
guys that's a hard decision
first off every time i was doing
stand-up for the last year i felt like a
gay man hmm
what does that mean what am i trying to
say
i'm doing something i don't want to do
like i'm doing something i didn't it was
like if i you ever seen l.a you were
seeing that later there's people you
would see in l.a that this you ever hear
like i was at a restaurant one night i
heard a guy and i'm thinking to myself
and i love gay men yeah i was thinking
to myself dan nobody is gay can be this
gay
nobody could be this [__] gay
only in l.a could somebody move to l.a
become gay
and then when they move out of l.a they
switch back to big and [__] uh
you know
ann heisch whatever he did
bunch of people just happen to be gay in
that way when they get there then 10
years later you look at facebook they
got a family
what happened they became gay to be part
of the [__] game and i hate to say
this but it's true
so they could belong to something they
could just go belong to that and they'll
take it in the ass like what's the
difference say you know i [__] chick
some guy fingered me in the ass what's a
dick in the ass at this point i'll do it
for three four years just to get some
work and hang out and have friends and
get invited to parties and then one day
when nobody wants me as an actor i'm a
failure because i am i'll [__] move
back to florida find a woman what i'm
trying to say is that there's it's like
me trying to fake gay like i i just
didn't want to do comedy no more i just
didn't it wasn't in my realm no more
recently
i'm falling in love with it again like i
watched the rodney special the other
night yeah you know i watched the
kenneth especially all night that's what
i wanted
i couldn't even watch a special the only
special i watched was
allie wong's new special that was the
only one
and she inspired me a little bit but now
i wanted to fall in love with it again
if you can't do comedy for free
you're not gonna do it yeah you're not
going to do it you know so
it's like when you did the
the small machine moving small engine
repair small engine repair that was
labor of luck that's it you didn't do it
for the money you did it because you
believed in the project that's how you
know you like what you do yeah yeah i
mean i i mean that's kind of
that's kind of for better or for worse
that's that's that's the whole thing
with me i mean i think the success of it
is just being invited back to come play
again you know what i mean it's like
that's that's that's what you that's
what you're aiming for so i'd be lost as
[__] without it now i see that you put a
podcast out there i told mike me and
mike have discussed it on the show and
off camera
i love it it's a video podcast
and we have videos here you know we have
a video and an audio
you did a video podcast that's just a
little bit more real and we were talking
about this before it's shot in the
winning time i like it i like how it
shot like all the angles you got
i like that nobody's neat you got a
backwards hat on some days yeah
you know you're not trying to be johnny
carson you're just trying to get the
he's trying to get the information out
to inform people what made you come up
with this i mean look it's not it's just
not honestly joey's not it's not about
me i got i got no real desire to
you know put myself out there anymore
and if i'm being dead honest about it i
i mean the the the guys that i really
respect that that
you know
really do what i do and and actors you
know they
i i think putting less of yourself out
there is probably better and and and the
more people kind of get to know
who i am who john bernthal is the less
they're going to believe me as a doctor
as the punisher or as the [__]
baseball player whatever it is and and
there's been this whole thing you know
among actors that they always say you
know maintain your mystery and all that
[__]
and um look i i i
you know for me it really kind of came
down to me just sort of being kind of
like disgusted
with
discourse in in in the country i just
kind of got to a point as a dad and as
an american where i was just like you
you can't have
there's there's no room to to have a
discussion anymore without having an
agenda without saying i'm on this side
or this side and and i feel like so many
of the kind of major issues
of the day are being led by people who
have no experience with those issues
it's some [__] celebrity or pundit or
so-called expert but you know for me i
just know i've been
i've been like super [__] blessed man
by by
the both the life i've led and and the
career that i've had that i've gotten to
really know and and and have real
relationships with people who have
really walked the walk so you know the
folks on my show are are
you know they're they're um they're cops
they're they're special forces soldiers
their surgeons their coaches their
teachers their civil rights lawyers um
all kinds of political agendas all kinds
of races and religions and sexuality
whatever the [__] they are the only
criteria is they're they're real they
actually walk the walk they got the
respect of their community they got the
respect of the people they work with um
they've really done the things that
they're talking about what i find is
people who have really walked in those
valleys and and and really
you know had boots on the [__] ground
of that [__] they go into life with
empathy they go into life like
understanding folks on the quote unquote
other side you know look man i i mean we
talk about policing with this new show
um look man i'm sure i'm i'm sure
sometime in your life you've been beaten
up by a cop i sure as [__] have been
beaten up by a cop and and and and look
that being said some of my best friends
in the world are cops i don't [__]
hate i've also experienced unbelievable
sublime generosity and kindness from
cops
i've been protected by cops and like the
fact is in this country you know for
some reason now
we've confused you know being completely
[__] steadfast in your views
completely unchanging it's my way or the
highway as being patriotic or strong or
tough where to me there's nothing more
cowardly there's nothing more
un-american than saying it's my way or
the highway this country is about
[__] sitting down with people that
might think differently than you and
having a [__] beer and being like hey
man you might teach me something i might
teach you something we still love our
kids we still love our sports we still
and we can go to we and you know what
man like push comes to shove we will
fight together as americans to preserve
this country it's the greatest country
on [__] earth and i think we've
become so divided you know i i'll tell
you
you know
one of the things on the show that i'm
i'm most excited about is um in a few
cases and folks in shreveport folks in
south central los angeles and dc and
baltimore i've had guys come on who are
either active or ex-gang members who
have done you know
you know decades in prison some of them
some of them did a life sentence one guy
that i had got out of super max in
florence colorado was locked up with
larry hoover and i had them on literally
with sometimes with the cop that put
them away and what i found is like here
are two people on on opposing sides
quote unquote of this sort of argument
about race and policing in this country
but yet they're finishing each other's
sentences they're more alike than they
are different they both lost time they
both lost friends they both lost loved
ones to this you know war on drugs
whatever this is yet
they find fault with their own groups
they find they can reach across the
quote unquote [__] aisle and say hey
here's a here's a cop that i really
[__] respected or you know what
here's a gang member i really respected
i really respected the way he was there
his loyalty that he showed how he
protected people in his community and
and to me it's like if these folks can
do that we all should be able to do that
and so
again without wanting
the the hardest thing for me about doing
the show is that it's it's it's i'm
asking a lot of people that aren't used
to coming on camera aren't used to
coming on the mic people that i really
[__] love and respect and who have
opened up their lives to me
which i think is sacred and i'm asking
them to open up their lives to you know
whatever platform i have but i i
genuinely [__] believe that those are
the people that we should be listening
to i love the people we have on i don't
know what the [__] i'm doing i'm not an
interviewer i'm not like good at this
i'm not but it is not about celebrities
it's not about [__] acting it's not
about it's literally about discourse and
spending some time with people who again
who walk the walk they don't just talk
about it
it's crazy how one of the biggest
problems i have taking pictures with
people yeah is do you know who you're
taking a picture with
i stole a chain a can of chains that
belonged to handicapped kids one time i
took it
but you stole i went to get ice cream
yeah but if i went to like get ice cream
to a milkshake and i had like 18 i
needed 20 to go into the city to get a
bag of reefer yeah and that's not even
taking the bus i'm walking over the
george washington bridge right what i'm
trying to say is a real point there that
in life one time i went to get something
and there was a mug a can where you put
your change and there was a couple
dollars i took the camp
just took the can in 1993 why because
i'm a [__] thief yeah you know i went
to prison i did all these mistakes
i always want to celebrate like i always
go why would you want to take a picture
of me there's a doctor somewhere that's
gonna save the kid's life that's right
and you want to take a picture with a
friend that's right because he cracked a
few jokes because you because they smoke
dope are you [__] what is wrong with
you that's right go take a picture with
a cop that just gave birth to a kid in a
[__] fire like he just saved the
woman and the the baby was [__] you
know those are the people that we should
celebrate and we don't celebrate them no
matter what we don't only celebrate the
day celebrating that's it and then we
want to like talk about all these issues
we want to you know we want to we talk
about all these issues but the only way
we can talk about them is by saying
you're either on this side or that side
and with the folks that are actually
living it they don't pick size they're
busy doing it you know what i mean
they're busy doing it and they see
beauty and they see brutality in in the
life that they're living and they call
it out they judge people for the content
of their character and the [__] look
in their eye it's not because hey you're
on this team or you're on that team and
and
you know i look man i think for me it
kind of you know during the pandemic and
and and when the sort of the the the
height of the reaction to both george
floyd the the george floyd video and
then you know
during you know the verdict you know one
thing that i was really seeing is i was
like look man like i want to be out
there i believe in this
movement you know i believe that you
know what that guy did
you know i didn't need to be there
seeing that video that that that that
that was just a level of disgusting
horrifying violence that i knew that
that needed to be weeded out and i knew
that there was something in the culture
of policing that needed to change with
that it was it was i needed be to be a
part of that movement i needed to be out
on the streets i needed to be a part of
that protest but then i also saw on tv
people throwing [__] bottles at cops
people [__] hurling insults at cops
and each one of those cops has a family
they've got wives or husbands or kids or
brothers and sisters they're all human
beings trying to do the best they can
and this is one guy so anytime i go out
to the protest i go down to newton
division and i go talk to the cops too
and i just didn't understand why you
couldn't be both why can't you be
black lives matters and pro pro police
why can't you do that and and what was
crazy is the folks who are actually from
these communities you know everyone's
saying defund the police let's see the
people who are from these communities
you go talk to the folks in in
shreveport louisiana where the murder
rate is just [__] skyrocketing i'm
talking to people in some of the you
know most ignored communities in that
[__] city they said we need more
policing you go to baltimore we need
more [__] policing baltimore there's
been so much police corruption but i
talked to my buddy tony maggio or keith
gagliano guys who grew up in [__]
east baltimore who are policing for the
right reasons and who are community mind
they got the respect of their community
they're [__] aggressive ass serious
cops and the community [__] loves
them and they love the community they're
doing it for the right reasons it's just
it's so much more
complicated than anyone wants to make
this [__] all these issues you know it's
like when i you know talking to my
friend you know in moscow we had on on
the podcast the other day to talk about
what what information is really like
over there and what people are really
here on on the ground in moscow
it sucks because
you know right now so much of the
information is so [__] agenda driven
and again like joe you know me i'm a
[__] [__] who says lines for a
living that somebody else wrote i put
makeup on like i researched the [__] out
of my [__] but i am not the guy to be
delivering political discourse so this
guy like i is not about you but these
[__] people i know for a fact we need
to start listening to people who
actually do this [__] who actually have
seen it you want to talk about war you
want to talk about combat talk to
special forces soldiers talk to marines
talk to guys who have actually been
there talk about what they've seen like
let them open up about their experiences
don't listen to some [__] who's
just pontificating about books and he's
never set foot there i just i know
in my gut that that's the answer i know
that's the answer for our kids i know we
got it
those are the people that that need the
mic right now so that's that's what
we're trying to do with the show it's a
great [__] show thank you man thank
you i appreciate it man thank you and i
like the cuts i like the
you know you're going to put time into
this go for it yeah yeah go for it bro
go for it
get [__] everybody that you can on
there that you could put a light on to
show people what these people look at
what that we we gave a light to the
[__] fire department right
after 9 11. we loved them yep and now we
don't want to [__] give them benefits
when they're dying of cancer that's
right
you know we always put you know we love
[__] the nurses and the doctors who
saved us over the pandemic but then we
fired them
over a [__] mandate and now you know
i mean it's just never
it's never they could never and these
are the people the lunch lady that's
right you know i think about a lot in my
[__] day mrs sabatino yeah a lady who
used the lunch lady in my grandma's
school
think about what a lunch lady goes
that's right she some sometimes kids
don't have money they put the 55 cents
up for you whatever it is for the milk
and the cookie
sometimes she would wink at me and give
me an extra cookie that lady controlled
those students okay and she didn't even
know with love and
the effect the effect that that adults
have on kids how can i [__] remember
that from my childhood that's right i
still remember her probably more so than
a bunch of your teachers people right
and well let's talk about teachers yeah
[__] the team that's what i'm doing
saturday where are you going to see my
freshman year teacher uh he's in from
florida he helped me out in 85.
my other teacher mr barron i took him to
the [__] grudge match oh really
i took mr terranova to the longest yard
premiere wow those teachers people don't
respect teachers and they got a bad rap
last year that's right during the
pandemic and i got said some [__] about
teachers i'm sorry
but teachers spend
seven hours a day with you that's more
than your [__] passion your parents
get home at five [__]
and they put you in bed at nine that's
five that's five [__] hours where i
come from these teachers these men and
women these coaches they're with you all
[__] day they know you
better than your [__] parents at one
point
and we don't give them nothing they have
to fight for [__] every month i got to
donate to some [__]
teachers 16 so they could get students
pencils
because yeah i do it every [__] month
they hit me from i'm getting hit from
schools in africa yeah everybody i
donate to every [__] school because i
teachers need supplies and the [__]
schools don't reimburse them it comes
out of their pockets so they're not
making any moolah and then i got to pay
for [__] for these [__] kids so these
are the tough jobs we don't look at man
that's right and those are the people i
talked to
i loved that i speak spanish so i could
talk to the busboy at the restaurant so
when your white ass ain't got no water
and bread i got water and bread like a
[__] because i gave that guy a
ten dollar bill when i came in guess who
you know who gave him a ten dollar bill
the last time somebody gave a ten dollar
bill when he left mexico and his mother
put a dent in his pocket to cross the
[__] fence and to last for a month
so these are the people that need
attention in this country these are the
people that need attention in this world
and we can learn man you learn from you
learn
[Music]
so i mean these are all the things that
these are the people that we should be
celebrating
especially after what this country went
through the last two [__] years so
you know
whatever
whatever the [__] yeah
what's on the agenda what's going on
with you you know man i'm just i'm here
promoting the wheel in the city you know
the the the hbo show i i uh i just been
doing a little bit of press and then um
you know i got to get back to work i
could fly out in a couple hours back
back to uh california um hopefully i'll
get to my kids games again that's really
what i want to [__] do i want you to
tell them the story about the day i
called you in baltimore and you were on
the set and you're like joey d hold on
one second and all of a sudden it's like
yeah yeah i got it all of a sudden you
got back on you're not going to believe
what happened some guy just ran on the
set and i had to punch him oh you were
you were i talked i was on the phone
with you i was on the phone with you
yeah we were talking about something and
you're like you're not going to believe
what's going to happen wow i'm doing a
scene and some guy just ran yeah that
happened yeah and we got into a fist
fight wow we thought it was election i
talked to you that day
man we were doing that we're doing that
i think it'll come out maybe is it is it
next episode i'm not sure which episode
it's in but we were doing the uprising
scene with which we were shooting it at
you know that they what david simon and
those guys do so [__] right i mean
you know you love the wire i love the
wire you know but you know these guys
they have such unbelievable access and
respect and reverence for the city of
baltimore they've spent their entire him
and george pelicanos they've they spent
their entire careers there so you you
you know it it's they do it
we shot every scene that went down every
everything that happens in the show
really happened and we really shot it
where it happened a lot of times with
the real cops and with the real victims
or with the real perpetrator whatever it
is you know and and and we're shooting
it with the community that show was
being shot for the city of baltimore by
the city of baltimore with the city of
baltimore and so we were shooting you
know the uprising scene at mcdowan mall
where it actually went down where you
know where you know wayne jenkins his
character i show up he shows up to this
big protest and some guys threw some
bricks at some cops so wayne runs in he
gets the guy through the bricks of the
cops he [__] dragged him to the
ground and takes him into custody and it
was this sort of moment where wayne
really stood up for the other cops
whatever so we're doing that scene all
day and they told us before we got there
they're like look this is going to be a
really sensitive day and again huge
respect to the producers like it was all
people who were actually in the uprising
were there that day everybody who i was
standing on the line with they were real
baltimore police officers so it was a it
was a you know like i just saw so much
respect for these guys to show up and do
that you know you're making you're
making a show about police corruption in
baltimore i'm going on right along with
these guys they open their hearts to me
and that's not because i'm a great guy
it's because what they did with the wire
they said hey the wire tells the truth
if you [__] are here to tell the
truth tell the [__] truth expose
whatever the [__] you want because we
respect the truth so we're out there
shooting this scene
and i'm doing like you know you do like
40 [__] takes it's a big thing and
i've done like 20 and these are all
stunt guys that i used to [__] with on
the punisher i know all these guys and
you know we've got it choreographed i'm
beating this guy we got you know we're
making it rougher and rough or rougher
so all of a sudden they throw the brick
you know the bricks made it like [__]
plaster it doesn't hurt i block it with
my my [__] shield and then i run out
there
and all of a sudden there's this guy
with dreadlocks i've done it 20 times
i'm like who's this [__] guy like i
never you know and we talked about this
really sometimes extras do like weird
[__] you know like they want to get into
the scene but i'm like we've done it 20
times i know all these guys by name and
now there's this guy like running at me
with these [__] dreadlocks i'm like
who's this [__] clown and i go oh my
god is he about to sock me and he
[__] reaches back i'm like this
dude's gonna [__] hit me and sure
enough he just throws a [__] right
hand right at my [__] head and the
last second i blocked it with uh my riot
shield but it hit my face i felt it cut
my i felt it cut my face and i just
figured all right he's a background
actor but if he's going to take a swing
at me i'm going to take sway him you
know so i just like wow wow and i hit
him with this right hand i hit him like
right in the eye and he fell down
and then we finished the scene we're
like [__] around doing our thing and
then uh the scene was over
and i go
and i'm like looking around to see what
happened the guy walks up to me joey his
his eye is like i mean he's bleeding
profusely from his eye and he comes over
to me and he gives me a [__] hug he
goes yo dawg you a real one man you a
real one and he hugged me then he looks
to his right
three real baltimore
city police officers [__] are chasing
him and he runs off he just happened to
be running by and he's like yo i'm gonna
go knock that [__] out on tv and
that's baltimore and like the fact that
he gave me a hug after that it was the
most baltimore thing like he showed me
respect you know what i mean it was
incredible man and then but like you
know then like i had this big and then i
guess i talked to you which is nice
right there right right so crazy right
then you're not gonna believe what
[__] happened yeah you're like i
believe this yeah yeah i'm like jesus
christ yes
crazy it's crazy it's crazy and it was
[__] up because then i had this like
line of blood on my face from the
[__] shield so then you know yeah and
then it's like it's got a match we got
to wait you know i'm i'm sitting there
like i'm going to lose takes because
they got to stop the bleeding because it
won't match and i just i want my takes
you only got like half a day to shoot
the scene but you know [__] actors
you know what's funny you mentioned
travolta travolta stallone before
i only saw that [__] for two
minutes on grudge match yeah yeah
as i was walking in
he as i was walking in he was walking
out he was in the yard and i stood out
there i didn't know whether i should go
in the [__] building or not the gym
i was ready to go in the gym but i saw
him on the parking lot
and i go i gotta go up to that
[__] and say something
and as i went over like this i saw him
go like this in the
in the in the in the suv he was looking
at himself whilst he went like this
thing went
like together tricep shot and i go
there's nothing i got to say to him
right now there's nothing i got to say
that's the best i love him
i [__] love that [__] i mean
how can you he's my hero i mean i love
that [__] and like you talk
about like a [__] underdog like when
you get into that rocky story and what
he did and what he's done for you like
he's a [__] hero man he's [__] him
but it was so interesting to see him i
mean like i don't know who's like how
many people watch that movie whatever
but it was so [__] interesting to see
him and de niro just
two titans [__] titans legends
italian americans came up at the exact
same time and he like you [__] rocky
like to do what he did in rocky like he
i mean he is a [__]
brilliant artist and then you've got de
niro who's also came up at the same time
he's considered one of the most
brilliant artists american artists
probably of all time right he's in the
top five i don't know at least for me
right but these guys they made decisions
along their career that were so
fundamentally different you know he went
on he did rambo he did [__] uh
uh uh uh uh like all those big [__]
franchises
tango and cash
did he do robocop or was that did he do
was that schwarzenegger
no no what was the cop one that he did
like the robot oh you know what i'm
talking about yes the one with uh what's
yeah
is that right
you know what my point is the point is
is like that's the way and nothing
against him like that's he was a huge
action you know franchise star and and
de niro just kept on going out and doing
and it was just like seeing these
guys you know kind of being pitted
against each other in a movie
when they have so many similarities but
so many differences and they come from
the exact same
you know uh era and and background but
they've lived and like i think they both
sort of had envies and jealousies and
and admirations of each other it was
extraordinary i i found it [__]
fascinating and for me man you know like
i'm i'm just a de niro guy man so i was
just like you know i played his son so i
was just all about de niro and then i
was so like protective you know what i
mean of of him but it was such a it was
such a such a fast it was that was a
crazy shoot man that was a crazy i
learned a lot on that shoot like it was
just
a really neat uh
who cracked me up hello cool jay when he
called deniro benjamin buttons
he was like this motherfucker's benjamin
button
he's like everybody in there was really
cool i still talk to the director peter
peter he's great yeah people peter i
still talk to people from time to time
but it's just uh
i love the last [__] rambo oh yeah
did you see it yeah the last one in
mexico and then he re-cut it yeah and he
[__] holy [__] with that [__]
finger in the shoulder and all that
stuff that was the most violent one he
ever made but look at what he did i mean
look at what he did in in creed you know
what i mean he's free that's right
beautiful actor man he's he's he's he's
got so much heart you know i mean he's
not gonna be in this one in the new one
yeah no i don't think so no i don't
think so like that's how to see him he's
[__] old yeah and to see what he's
doing he's still out there i i [__]
just it's just
he was he made more money anybody doing
this pandemic oh yeah they played three
of his movies that's right every [__]
day yeah every [__] day you know so
he's got a new show he's doing a new
moment with taylor sheridan yeah yeah
and taylor's the great i mean he's the
greatest he's the [__] i've done three
things for taylor he's the greatest
director
i i don't know if taylor's director
should you know taylor's got an empire
now you know yellowstone in 1883 and
like you know he's doing all that you
know i think the other one's like mayor
of of of kingstown maybe i'm probably
butchering the name but he's got
you know taylor taylor was a [__]
actor on sons of anarchy he played the
cop on sons of anarchy and you know man
he just
he got sick of telling other people
stories he got sick of you know hanging
out with a bunch of guys trying to be
tough bikers you know and taylor's a
tough [__] he's exactly what he
said he was the main cop
he was the main cop in the first few
seasons uh like that like the he was
sort of like the villain in a way you
know he was like the guy that you know
he's trying to keep peace in the town
the white dude the white dude that's
taylor sheridan it was a skinny that was
a little bit
sons of anarchy and then there was uh
the old guy that's right he's the
younger guy the handsome younger yeah
that's taylor sheridan and so he said
you know what man i'm done with this
[__] i'm gonna go write a script he
[__] wrote sicario you know what i
mean and then he got done with that he
wrote sicario and then he got done with
that and he wrote hell or high water
then he got done with that and he wrote
wind river and directed it
you know and then he
and now he's got he's got an empire he's
and and he's speaking to people
who hollywood isn't really speaking to
very much anymore yellowstone is like
the biggest [__] show in the world
it's
[__] amazing
and taylor is just like he's done things
his own way and and he's refused to play
ball
and and and and he's i mean
you know man like you know how it is you
become a
serious regular on a show like sansa
anarchy he walked away from that to
write he had never written anything and
he's been um such a kind
like supporter of mine how you know when
i started writing you you know i wrote
this show called the bottoms um you know
which we just sold to hbo like that
you know he was the first guy i went to
he was the first guy that said write
this do this yourself he's like i'll
help you i'll give you advice and he
supported me stuck by me um he's he's a
beautiful beautiful guy taylor sherry
he's brilliant and i think now that he's
got stallone like this will be even a
new iteration of stallone with with
taylor it's going to be great now taylor
wrote this yeah yeah so it's a mob thing
yeah yeah it's a mafia it's a mob show
yeah and it's uh terrence winter is it
is it that's what i heard i don't i
think tyrants is the executive producer
that might be right that might be
that might be it's going to be a good
show it'll be great they didn't call me
to go to oklahoma so yeah yeah tulsa
king that's right
that's what it's called you call them
joey what are you guys doing no they
didn't want me for the pilot they said
they were they had something
okay in the future that they might
whatever one last question
yeah why the [__] were you in this
sandra bernhardt movie
jesus christ
me and my wife were like what the [__]
why is he in this sandra bernard movie
goddammit
what's her name bullock bullock but i
saw i knew what you meant which is
beautiful
listen listen listen listen
people give me a hard time dude
listen first of all i i i here's the
thing she called me she called me i
remember exactly where i was yeah i was
sitting in the i was sitting in the
parking lot you know where the uh what's
that great [__] um breakfast spot on
fairfax on uh sunset in fairfax i know
you know what i'm talking about right
next to director's guild across the
street from the starbucks there what's
it called
the [__] waffle the griddle the
griddle the [__] listen bro
he's like an advertisement for smoking
weed you know how much [__] weed he's
smoking he remembers everything no i
remember that place called
lindsay lohan went in there the weekend
trial
oh really did you ever go in there yeah
i mean that play how great is that the
only problem i got is that you got to
wait online
so i used to pull up there and go beep
beep you [__] sheep [__] here
there's bagels across the street that
would pull off and they'd go why is he
yelling at us because you're standing on
stand in line for [__] eggs not for
eggs
anybody can make an egg i don't stand in
line for food okay anybody can make an
egg but yeah goodbye it's amazing what
they do they do it it really is it's a
breakfast
it's a breakfast beyond what you know
you get an omelet like this [__]
thing it's it's almost like you can't
believe what they're doing in there it's
it's right right and but big man like
big potatoes for breakfast amazing chili
amazing like they got a ton of huge menu
huge menu it's a great place it's a
great [__] place but see we're so
packed so i would just stay in the car
and go south and go to dukes
i like dukes next to whiskey i like
dukes on sunset yeah i mean i used to go
to dukes when i first came came to town
when i first came to l.a i go to duke's
all time but but i'm sitting there in
the [__] parking lot behind where is
it the griddle the drizzle
i'm sitting there in the griddle
and you know i i talked to the director
of that movie and and she seemed great
she did a movie she's german she did a
german movie called system crashers that
was so [__] good i mean so and for me
like that's my thing man if i just want
to work with great directors i don't
give a [__] if it's a big part little
but i really don't care about it i just
want to be with great directors but i
will say i i said to them look i can't
do this one like i just can't like i'm
too busy i get too much going on i can't
do this i can't do another you know like
i want to work with you but i you know
like cutting fish and like not doing
anything i can't do it and then uh
[__] sandy bullet called me she
called me and she just said look i need
you to do this i need you and like the
truth is man like call whatever i had so
much respect for the fact that she did
that she said i see you in this i want
it to be you nor the director loves you
like i want to do these scenes with you
and she's like i'll make it easy on you
we'll get you in and out but like i
really wanted to be you like dude like
do this for me i'm like [__] man like i
had you know gravity go i watch gravity
with my kids the other day i mean sandy
bullock is a [__] gangster santa
barbara is a gangster but it's time to a
good person she's a good good girl
i mean she got one let me tell you
something else about sandy bullock all
these mother all these movie stars with
their like you know 10 person security
details and this team of [__] navy
seals and all this [__] that only draws
more attention to them no one's going to
do [__] [__] to them anyways right
sandy bullock has got one guy pete i
think his name's pete and he's a retired
uh lapd detective this guy is like
remember that show hunter yes remember
hunter yes this guy looks like [__]
hunter this guy like he's got gray hair
he smokes cigarettes he's probably like
six five you know he'll like carry her
bag or carry her sweater
he does ever it's just him it's just him
and we were on the streets of [__] um
you know on hastings that down hastings
in vancouver you know where like
it's kind of like what's it's it's it's
canada's skid row it's hastings right
it's skid row right so it's like it's
just like our skid row people aren't
like [__] themselves nobody's got a
gun you know what i mean so
she's walking across the street and he's
just i mean he's just like this [__]
cool ass old handsome dude with his
aviator smoking a cigarette holding her
[__] back and all of a sudden she's
walking across the street in a scene and
some guy out of nowhere just starts
running at her this [__] does
not even pick up his pace joey he just
[__] mid-sentence [__] puts a
cigarette down walks over [__] grabs
that [__] by the arm two inches
away from her and just [__] takes him
off the street it's like she didn't even
notice this guy is like got her like
that he's he's he's and it just says so
much about her that that's who's in you
know they've been together forever he
loves her he loves the family i i i got
so much good to say about sandra bullock
man so like she asked i came you know
what i mean that's okay i love you i
love you too i'm happy you swung by
today uh get a chance to watch we own
the night i love it it's going we're on
this city we're on the city you know me
though yeah it don't matter i don't even
you know nine o'clock monday that's all
you need to [__] know
hbo i love this [__]
one of the best in the business and if
hollywood goes how i want it the next
charles bronson that's it plain and
[__] simple hopefully he'll win the
oscar and send an indian to pick it up
like marlon brando you know what i'm
saying
i love you i love you thanks for coming
on yeah thank you for having me bro
all right i want to thank you
[__] i want to thank john
bernthal for coming on today
i love you guys i love the support you
give me we had a good week this week the
joint is brought to you by from the
heart of [__] new jersey
draftkings the cap slicer the peruvian
necktie the banana split there's tons of
way to come out on top and the octagon
even a [__] knockout with draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of ufc 274 new customers can bet
five hours on any fighter to win and get
a hundred and fifty dollars in free bets
if they do so choose your fighter sit
back and watch the action unfold
anything can happen on fight night but
you got a short thing with draftkings
sportsbook bet five dollars and get 150
and free bets if the fighter wins plus
you got the nba playoffs plus you got
baseball this is the time of the year to
make some little bit of cash before
mother's day download the draftking
sports book app use promo code joey and
throw down five dollars on any ufc 274
fighter to win and get a hundred and
fifty dollars in free bets that they do
when they do that's co joey this
saturday at draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the ufc
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply but listen get on that gagey
[__] uh
oliveira fight the joint is also brought
to you by cbd line i don't think i'd be
here if it wasn't for cbd lion they've
kept me together this whole year with my
[__] creaks and bends and pains
whether it's the cream whether it's the
kinesiology tape whether it's the
capsules
whether it's the gummy bears with
melatonin cbd lion is right there for
you number one in what they do so do me
a favor
go to cbdline.com
read the third-party lab results and you
make your decision
this is what you want to be putting in
to your body when it needs help i'll
tell you a little secret i've been using
cbd
before i go to the gym the tincture
[__] tremendous cbd lion
code joey j-o-e-y and get you 20 off i
want to thank draftkings i want to thank
stamps.com
i want to thank manscape i want to thank
lucy i want to thank cbd lion all these
i love you with all my heart i want to
thank john bernthal and lisa for being
on i want to thank mike i want to thank
all of you for having my [__]
back have a great weekend i'll be back
monday morning
tip top magu remember don't kill the
mexican
[Music]
so
you